welcome back to cbs mornings we continue
to follow what the state department is
calling the wrongful detainment of
brittany griner that's the wnba star
who's been in russian custody since
february this morning we're learning the
russian foreign ministry is saying it is
quote difficult at the moment to engage
in any kind of prisoner exchange with
the u.s in phoenix last night griner's
fans rallied to demand her freedom to
bring her home ed o'keefe is following
developments from the white house ed
good morning dana good morning good to
see you as you said supporters sat at
her home court last night ahead of her
second scheduled court appearance today
in a moscow area courtroom
truthfully
i can't rest as her humanity is being
stripped from her
supporters of the 31 year old basketball
star gathered at footprint center home
of her wnba team the phoenix mercury to
rally for brittany griner's return home
griner's wife sharon addressed the crowd
i'm frustrated that 140 days have passed
since my wife
has been able to speak to me
to our family and to our friends
i'm frustrated that my wife is not going
to get justice
the rally came after the star olympian
penned an independence day letter to the
president who read it and responded with
a phone call to sherelle
the white house says the president told
her he's working to ensure the release
of brittany as well as the release of
paul whelan and other u.s nationals who
were wrongfully detained or held hostage
in russia and around the world you know
why the outreach to some families and
not others that statement sparked
criticism from whelan's sister who says
the president hasn't called her family
directly about securing her brother's
release whoever thought this was a good
idea has to remember that other families
with far less resources have been
waiting for years and years to see some
action to bring their loved ones home
paul weyland is serving a 16-year
sentence on an espionage charge ever
since being detained in russia in 2018.
as for the president he is said to have
written a response to brittany griner
in response to that letter she sent him
on independence day but the white house
has not yet revealed the contents of
that message dana
all right ed thank you